TAKEN A LOT OF THE HEAT OFF AND
SAY KOPITAR.
>> TALK ABOUT ANOTHER GUY WHO'S,
RIGHT ON, AND CAL ROUGHSHOD
RIGHT THERE CANADA, LOOKING FOR
SCORES IN THE NATIONAL HOCKEY
LEAGUE,
BEING
>> HERE COMES KEMP A, THE SHOT,
ATTACK.IS SKATES OFS THE SHOT.
SCHEIFELE SHOOTS AND THAT'S
>> SCHEIFELE LOSES THE DRAW TO
KOPITAR., ATHANASIOU.
SKIPPED BY HIM, NASH, TRYING
THE BENCH MIN GONE
ON.
ROY, UP TOP, HAS A LOOK.,
SVECHNIKOV, IN THE CORNER.
ELEMENT OF.
>> Kevin: IT.
>> SHAWN MICHAELS AND THREE
ASSISTS IN HIS PAST FOUR GAMES.
WERE HAPPY
>> IT'S BEEN A STRUGGLE FOR SOME
OF THESE TOP GUYS TO PRODUCE.
WHEELER OUT THERE TO GET A
SCHEIFELE. ROY, AT
BUT THAT WILTH OF
SCORING AND WHAT DO BALL HAS
DONE, WITH THE HELP OF MORE
CLAGUE BEING TRACKED. KNOW DOIN,
KOPITAR DOING IT, BUT HE'S THE
PRESSURE GOALSCORER, AND NOW
CREDIT ON THIS -- THIS ONE. PARL
TWO ON ONE.
GRUNDSTROM DECIDES TO LEFT
MOVE UP.
HE DID, GOING TOWAR TO STANLEY.
THERE, THAT ALLOWED KUPARI TO
COME IN WITH SPEED.O DANAULT.
CHANCE FOR KUPAR WATCH
WHAT COPP DOES, SUCH A SMART, S.
>> Announcer: THIS OVERTIME
BROUGHT TO YOU BY SUBWAY.
NEW POTATO BUN S TO MAKE
THE SAVE.
>> SUCH A SMART PLAY.
HE LOOKED OFF KOPIT